[Music]
are you gonna answer that
it's not mine
sorry who is this
do I have your attention could I do
something to you
what do you want drive to this location
honey Something's Happened there's a man
who's put a bomb in the car under our
seats there are pressure triggers
can't get up the car will explode
we're here listen very carefully or I
kill you open the glove box
why are you doing this what have I ever
done to you this life or yours nah I'm
your best friend
you think I'm the bomber
well I guess you've had a tough day
I know that you've lost a lot of money
for your clients who invested in your
fund
a lot of people are worried about you
[Music]
you've got everybody's attention man
it's all out there you can find him I
will I'm in control here no you're not
you hurt my darling son of a I
will kill you
What's it gonna be
Drive
[Music]